now also tonight yet more bewildering
blunders from yes the often giggling
vice president kamala harris who wants
to let us know she really likes the
internet i mean really likes it take a
look
context well the internet is an
essential part of life in the 21st
century can't get around it
can't get around without it
biden kamala and nancy pelosi
god help us all right now despite not
yet completing any of our other jobs you
know securing the southern border the
white house is now giving the vice
president more responsibilities now
heading up something called an online
policy task force whatever the hell that
means now you might be wondering what
exactly that task force will do
well at this point it seems to be
anybody's guess even the white house
press secretary doesn't appear to know
take a look
on the online policy tasks we'll receive
the vice president's leading that's
getting kicked off today um on a
background call last night we were told
that it's going to be different from the
disinformation governance board
in that it's going to focus on illegal
conduct online but the memo creating it
was a little bit broader and
mentioned and i'm quoting from the
document uh quote online harassment
abuse and disinformation campaigns
targeting women and lgbtqi plus
individuals who are public and political
figures
um could you clear up the disinformation
charge so i would need to uh talk to her
team i was not on the background call so
that specific uh
language that you're you're providing to
me i would just have to check in with
her
in other words i don't know a thing
about it either hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else